good morning everyone today we have dr.
Alan Goodman from Washington State
University here with us on science
mission and I want to give a little bit
background about him first he completed
his PhD from a Washington University
Seattle in bioengineering and because of
his passion for working in science later
on he continued various postdocs he
worked as a postdoc at Washington
University Seattle he moved to Spain and
had to continue his research then he
came back to United States and he worked
in University of Miami Florida and later
on he accepted a position as assistant
professor at Washington State University
Pullman where he is currently working he
is a passionate researcher and he has
worked in different areas including
virology immunogenicity as well as
host-pathogen interactions so throughout
his career he has mentored many students
he has published 20 post publications he
is an active member of various societies
he has worked as a reviewer as well as
editor for various publications and
apart from that he has also served as a
mentor as well as consultant for some of
the biopharma biotechnology companies so
I would like to welcome dr. Allen and
ask him some questions
good morning dr. Allen nice to have you
here all right thanks for having me can
you hear me yes okay are you able to
hear me yeah give me one second
I've been wearing dr. Allen hey good
morning how are you so I would like to
ask you a few questions would you like
to share some of your background okay so
about your research and what motivated
you to continue to work in this field um
it really all started when I was in the
undergraduate at Johns Hopkins and
working in various labs first in a lab
of infectious disease and then Chemical
Engineering which was really more like a
bioengineering lab and working on a
project or what trace how beads
fluorescent beads moved throughout a
cell and moved throughout the nucleus
and we hypothesize that these little
beads could almost act like you know
their movement could be like how a virus
moves through a cell so thinking about
that and applying it you know how these
these motions of these beads move and
thinking about them as viruses um you
know spawned me into wanting to study
biology so that's what I did at the
University of Washington and pretty much
throughout my scientific career now I
can't hear you anywhere
well still can't hear still nothing oh
sorry about that thank you so much for
the introduction and would you like to
share some information about how many
students are there in your lab what kind
of projects are you and they doing and
where some of the long term goals yes so
we have now two graduate students that
are permanently in the lab we've had a
number of rotation students so likely
taking on another student starting next
year and there's also about six
undergrads in the lab anywhere from
junior to senior level undergraduates at
Washington State University and a lab
manager so yeah we have a good lab good
size you know a lot of motivated
students all working on various projects
that I'll talk about you know during my
presentation but looking at all related
to the host immune response and using
different bacterial and viral pathogens
to understand ultimately disease and we
use a fly model as I'll talk about
because we can you know transfer the
knowledge gained in Drosophila to a
mammalian system especially when the
host proteins are host genes that were
studying have similar function great
yeah great - I'm trying to hear that and
I know you are you're a busy person you
have so many graduate undergraduate
students to work with
apart from stellar from science what
else do you enjoy doing yeah so spending
time outside spending time with the
family watching playing sports any kind
of outdoor activities reminiscing and
old video games when I have a chance
yeah things like that showing my my two
and a half year old son how to play very
old Nintendo games and helping him learn
to do that kind of stuff that is that's
great and also is there a particular
around role model that you always look
up to I might say all of my past you
know
mentors in the labs they've all given me
some perspective on how to
be a good scientist how to mentor other
students how to deal with the ups and
downs of academic research I'm sorry you
know I think I owe it to you know a lot
of my a lot of my future success to my
past Mentors that's great
and one last question as this broadcast
would be broadcasters were all the
scientists out there if you would like
to share some kind of vision that you
have or some kind of collaborations you
are looking for that might be helpful
this might be a good chance to share
that information yeah I think ultimately
is a fruit fly model system you know
looking at this very small organism that
where we know everything about all of
its genes very well
so looking towards collaborations into a
larger animal model like at school so we
can you know work with these you know
apart from you know mammalian mouse
models we can look at large farm animals
you know trying to move the research
into that some of the viruses we study
in fact some of the animals that are at
our that school looking you know for
collaborations in that regard would be
fruitful that's great yeah I mean like I
would like to request you to share your
presentation and feel free to go ahead
and start whenever you're ready okay
okay so is every will be able to see the
screen okay yes yes that's great yeah
okay so again thanks for having me the
title of the presentation is
conservation of host-pathogen
interactions in innate immunity in
insects in mammals so I'll start by
given a very brief introduction to an
eighth immunity
maybe my cursor is that able to to be
seen on the screen yes okay good so
innate immunity is an ancient form of
host defense initiated upon Florida
pathogen infection and the innate immune
response is triggered when a cell eat
when a cellular pattern recognition
receptor prr encounters a pathogen so
molecular pattern or a camp some you
know very basic examples of this are
excuse me what happened there we go are
the toll-like receptors three seven and
eight are a guy or PKR
that can recognize a motifs of a viral
infection or other toll-like receptors
like one two four five six nine can
recognize byproducts of bacterial
infection so sometimes when people think
of an eighth immunity and they see this
in a big spaghetti map of all these
different receptors different interests
intracellular mediators transcription
factors and they can look you know
pretty daunting to under try to
understand you know how all of this
plays together but one thing about this
this map is that you can see there's
some color coding so we like to think of
it as you know we think of the receptors
these intracellular mediators as
families and then these transcription
factors here in blue home and then we
specifically focus on just a couple of
these pathways some of which are like I
mentioned the toll-like receptor
signaling so that's just one part of
this really big map or what's called the
rig I like receptor signaling
recognizing viral in this case RNA
double-stranded RNA but also other
nucleic acids that can be sensed during
the viral infection so then to break it
down into you know much more simpler
terms as I mentioned there's the
pathogen associated molecular pattern
that can that is produced during viral
or bacterial infections and these act as
the input to the pattern recognition
receptor so then once that pattern
recognition receptor becomes activated
it'll signal through these adapter
molecules and then activate
transcription factors which can
translocate to the to the nucleus in the
innate immune response one of the major
outputs from the input of infection is
interferon beta so then once interferon
beta is induced and it can be secreted
from the initial initially infected cell
and then if your invader will engage the
type 1 interferon
sector which will activate again some
other mediator molecules can activate
the transcription factor step one which
will then translocate to the nucleus and
cause the induction of these interfere
and stimulated genes so just through the
induction of a single molecule like a
nephron beta there can be the induction
of hundreds of these interference
stimulated genes which will really
activate the immune response will allow
for a bridge to ultimately an adaptive
immune response because these
interference stimulated genes will
recruit other molecule other cells to
the site of infection that can that can
then take up antigen and cause a further
adaptive immune response but we're
really focused here on this initial set
of signaling signaling events from the
input of the infection to looking at the
output of that first trip sprint
transcription event in this case can be
interfering beta and as we'll talk about
during in a fly model there's things
called antimicrobial peptides that can
be induced during the innate immune
response we also focus on a molecule
called sting which is a nucleic acid
sensor it can recognize a cyclic
dinucleotides
and I'll focus a little more on that
pathway in this diagram
so when sting is activated it
translocates and can single interferon
beta induction so let's look over the
mechanism on how sting gets activated
so during viral or a bacterial infection
there can be intracellular DNA which
will activate this Molly called C gas
which stands for cyclic GMP synthase
that'll cause the metabolism of cyclic
dinucleotides which then can directly
bind to sting which normally sits at the
endoplasmic reticulum
when sting gets activated it actually
moves to areas that are perinuclear and
will activate NF Kappa B or an IR f3
transcription factors that will
translocate the nucleus and cause the
induction of interferon beta so the
take-home message here is that
intracellular of DNA due to bacterial
infections or viral infections will
activate C gas
activate stain which caused the
induction of interferon beta so an
important part about this diagram is
that in any innate immune pathways that
if there's defects in any of these
pathways an autoimmune disease can
develop so autoimmune disease is a major
health burden can affect 50 million it
affects 50 million Americans it's the
top ten cause of death in women under
the age of 65 the second highest cause
of chronic illness and results in a 50
to 70 billion dollar burden annually so
some of the diseases that are caused by
or that some of these autoimmune
diseases that are caused by defects in
anatomy are Crohn's disease or ear to
bowel syndrome lupus Sjogren's disease
are a cardiga Thierry's syndrome which
is which causes an defects of innate
immunity in the brain there's also this
disease called sting associated vascular
pathy which there's an actual mutation
in the molecule called sting sting is
hyperactive and causes these innate
immune responses in the absence of any
sort of infection so innate immune
dysfunction is central to these painful
and costly pathologies so we recently
reviewed some of these defects in both
nucleic acid sensing defects in nucleic
acid sensing of double-stranded RNA so
defects in rig-i signaling or other
molecules that are part of this RNA
sensing pathway so when there are
defects and some of these genes we get
there's a number of autoimmune diseases
and similarly defects in in DNA sensing
pathways can cause autoimmune pathology
so again I mentioned mutations and sting
caused this savy disease which because
of the hyper basically all these
autoimmune diseases are hyperactive
hyperactive ation of some of these
nucleic acids sensing molecules and so
they're basically signaling in the
absence of any infection and causing the
induction of these pro-inflammatory
cytokines which result in autoimmune
diseases
so the question that our lab you know
asks is can we utilize orthogonal animal
models to better understand the innate
immune pathways as they relate to
autoimmunity and specifically to
microbial infection because the overall
idea is that any kind of mutation or any
kind of activation of these genes of
these proteins and first off in the
absence of infection will result in
autoimmunity but if these if these
proteins can't signal properly during
infection then we have this you know
infection pathology so some of our
current lab projects are one an insect
virus mediated immune responses in
mammalian hosts we use Drosophila as a
model for coxiella brunetti infection
we're characterizing the drosophila
homolog of sting and then we're looking
at the intersection between innate
immunity and translational control
during zika infection so again I
mentioned that we use the fruit fly
model as a major model to understand how
do the innate immune responses evolve
and differ between this invertebrate and
potentially these mammalian systems so
we're making out we're doing a lot of
our work in the fruit fly model to
ultimately make discoveries of novel
genes that we can ask do they function
similarly in a mammalian system and if
so how can we pursue looking at those at
those genes at those proteins during
infection in a mouse model but we're not
quite here yet we're still trying to you
know do all of our basic research in the
in the fly model so some some of you may
know this some may not but innate
immunity was actually discovered in
fruit flies so fruit flies live in a
very caustic environment there's always
a number of bacterial or fungal
infections that can occur
there's parasitic wasps that will attack
the pupae of fruit flies and then
actually and this is a fungal infection
so this picture is actually from a fruit
fly that is lacking the toll protein so
similar to a mouse model that has the
toll-like receptors the toll gene was
identified in fruit flies and when
mutated it's overburdened by this fungal
infection
this is what led to the Nobel Prize in
2011 to Joule ha - Jules Hoffman who he
shared with a couple other researchers
who then further studied the toll-like
receptors in mammalian models so again I
mentioned that we want to utilize this
orthogonal fruit-fly model to
extrapolate into the mammalian model in
other insect models of pathogenic
infections so again going back to the to
the lab projects we'll start by you know
I mentioned these four projects with
that again the whole goal is to uncover
these evolutionarily conserved host
factors that are critical to the host
response to infection I'll start by
talking about these two projects that
are looking at insect virus mediated
immune responses and mammalian hosts and
then how to target the innate immune
response to reduce West Nile virus
infections these are primarily led by my
graduate student Laura Haller's and a
couple of undergraduates chastity
Trammell and grace Carol
and here's Laura so we'll first start
talking about this first project so we
used a DNA virus called invertebrate
iridescent by r6 it's a double strand
DNA virus but we found that it activates
an RNA sensing pathway in insects so
just a little bit background about
invertebrate iridescent by r6 so in
flies and mosquitoes the RNA
interference pathway is activated as an
as immune response to many viral
infections so RNA I acts as this you
know how RNA I axes and immune response
in mammals is still controversial so I
have e6 a very large double strand DNA
virus 212 kilobase genome the size of
the virion quite large 200 nanometers in
diameter so we wanted to ask how does
the mammalian innate immune response
react to this insect viral infection so
it doesn't issue an immune response in
mammalian cells and again just looking
at you know back to the the pathway is
that during an innate immune response in
mammalian systems there's activation of
these transcription factors are f3 and
NF kappa-b that lead to the induction of
type 1 interferon so here we're showing
that during a iv6 infection we can get
phosphorylation and activation of IRF 3
and then we get secretion of interferon
beta by 24 hours post infection post I a
v6 infection so we also see NF kappa-b
so this is looking at translocation of
NF kappa-b to the nucleus during a v6
infection so you can see very robust
activation of NF kappa-b has marked by
how it translocates to the nucleus but
willingly what we found is that while I
a v6 will infect mammalian cells and
cause an innate immune response it
actually does not replicate so normally
it replicates very well in Drosophila as
to cells so you can see this what's
called a basically a viral factory you
can see all these neurons that are
produced some of which contain nucleic
acids so the dark spots show that it's a
fully infectious Vireo and it contains
the viral DNA some of these capsules are
still open because they're they haven't
packaged the DNA but during infection
and mouse embryonic fibroblast we can
see these variants that have that have
infected the cell but they're not
replicating and we know we observed that
there was no increase in iv6 in mouse
everything fiberglassed both by using
qPCR methods and and tcid 50 or the
ability of infectious Furion's to be to
be replicated we next noise again i
mentioned that a lot of our our goal is
to use other tools to understand how
Drosophila how insect immunity and
mammalian immunity are similar and we
found that iv6 activates a conserved
immune response in mammalian cells so
here is showing the Dicer molecule which
is part of the RNA i pathway and Dicer
in drosophila things is healy helicase
domain which is important for binding
and sensing to double strand RNA and
this there's very high similarity in
this helicase domain to human Dicer and
actually human rib eye and that's the
the major innate immune double strand
RNA sensor in the mammalian systems so
high similarity among these helicase
domains
[Music]
between Drosophila and human species so
what we did here is look at if we knock
out some of these some of these genes in
a mammalian system that contain these
helicase domains how is the interferon
beta secretion affected during a v6
infections what we did was knock out
Dicer rig I MBA 5 or Mavs and we saw
that during infection in these knockout
embryonic fibroblast during high v6
infection there's markedly reduced
secretion of interferon beta so we next
asked now that we we made some you know
we discovered how high B 6 activates an
immune response but it doesn't replicate
we ask could that high b6 mediated
immune response so this induction of
interferon beta could it protect against
other viral infections especially though
especially types of infections that can
be transmitted from from insect vectors
to humans so we looked at how vsv or
West Nile virus infection occurs
following iv6 infections what we did was
we infected Mouse Dominic fiberglass
with iv6
then we collected that supernatant of
the infection and transferred them to
new mouse embryonic fibroblasts and then
we infected with West Nile virus or vsv
and we measured West Nile virus we used
the conjuring strain of West Nile or bsv
by plaque a/c so we noticed that I post
different times post vsv infection we
would see a reduction in the level of
vsv replication following priming of
cells with a v6 you know of super name
from IV six infected cells in same with
the conjured virus or West Nile virus
and we saw a marked reduction in the
ability of West Nile virus to replicate
after the cells were prior to the i/o v6
so overall we found that the RNA mediate
immune response to ib6 could protect
against subsequent parvo viral
infections when the next question we
wanted to ask was what genes drive the
insect
response to West Nile virus infection so
first of all we had to do was show that
West Nile virus infection is lethal to
adult for South LA so here we see
so either infected with West Nile or moc
infected we can see you know very we see
basically what we see mortality at least
flies and in wild-type flies but a
different wild-type flies strain we
observed that there was no difference
there was actually no lethality but the
key here is that there's these are two
different types of wild-type flies
literally caught from the wild so line
number 28 or line 5 66 what these are
are strains of over 200 fly lines that
are part of the Drosophila genetics
reference panel so this is a panel of
209 strains of wild-type caught flies
caught at a farmers market in Raleigh
North Carolina and all of these 209
strains have their genome sequence so
what we can do is we can perform
infections in all 200 fly lines look at
the rate of mortality and then perform
what's called the genome-wide
Association study to identify genes that
are controlling the rates of mortality
in these fly lines so ideas to then to
identify gene variants that are
significantly associated with the
complex trait of in our case response to
West Nile virus infection and again I
mentioned that these projects are
carried out by Laura and also chastity
and grace in the lab so we we infected
our fly lines and observed a normal
distribution of hazard ratios which is
essentially the ratio of mortality rates
from mock infected flies to West Nile
virus infected flies and then we were
able to perform the genome-wide
Association study using the hazard ratio
as input for that for that for that
algorithm we can we then were able to
produce a Manhattan plot showing some of
these significantly so genes that have
high significance and are likely to
somehow control infection so next the
next steps are to identify to do
mechanistic studies in flies that are
mutant for some
these jeans and we also were able to do
gene set enrichment analysis so taking
all the data of every single p-value of
for every for every gene we are able to
input that into this gene set enrichment
analysis and do gene ontology studies
and we found that many of the gene gene
ontology categories that are that are
significant could have some relation to
viral infection so again looking at you
know ATP ATP transport activities so
looking at energy activation of the JMK
pathway regulation of the toll pathway
again an immune response so RNA
processing so we mentioned earlier that
RNA viruses activate RNA i as an immune
response and we're seeing genes you know
genome calyx sets of genes that are
significantly regulated that are part of
some of these pathways dead box helicase
so again these helicase domains that are
part of sensing double-stranded RNA we
can see significant regulation of genes
in these categories so again I mentioned
the next steps are to mechanistically
dissect the function of these genes
during war style virus infection in fly
and also in mosquito models and as I
mentioned no much earlier during the
introduction we ultimately want to take
this into a mammalian model on
potentially a horse model so at WSU at
the vet campus we actually get a number
of horses here that have been infected
with West Nile virus and in the wild so
can we use some of these large animal
models to look at West Nile virus in
fashion so moving on to the next the
next set of projects we next talk about
the Drosophila models of coxiella
Brunetti infection and how that relates
to the Drosophila sting protein so these
experiments were primarily carried out
by Zack Howard an undergrad in the lab
and I we here ah sue what our lab
manager so to step back so what is
coxiella brunetti so it's a
gram-negative bacteria an infection with
as little as one bacterium can cause
disease and 50% of subjects coxiella
mostly infects ruminant animals so
they're commonly infected and
a reservoir for human infection so
farmers who come in contact with these
animals coxiella causes spontaneous
abortions so if that that's occurring in
goats sheep cows then farmers can become
sick in local epidemics can occur while
Ted coxiella is a category B
bioterrorism agent so any work with Cox
even a requires bsl-3 facilities so
here's the the mate one of the major
virulence factors of cocktail brunetti
is a is this long lip Omaha logo sac
saccharide from this poem antigen that's
on the surface of coxiella brunetti so
this is the virulent phase one strain of
coxiella but an a virulent strain was
cloned and produced in 1986 at Rocky
Mountain National Labs and simply that a
virulent phased whose drain lacks that
that.oh antigen which can subvert innate
immune responses and subvert all immune
responses in infected animals so we
wanted to ask will that a virulent
strain in fact Drosophila so this phase
2 strain we can work with in BSL to
facilities we can it does not infect
animals with mammals with competent
immune systems but any kind of knockout
mouse that's lacks toll-like receptors
this phase 2 strain is virulent but we
want to ask will it infect and cause
mortality and wild-type drosophila so we
found that cocktail infection is indeed
lethal to adult adult flies so looking
at both males and females infecting them
with 10,000 bacteria per fly you can see
a drastic decrease in survival and both
males and females and we saw that there
that the the bacteria is indeed
replicating in these flies so using what
we're doing is measuring genome
equivalents so this is a way to measure
how many essentially coxiella genomes
there are infected animals the reason we
do that is because doing a colony
forming units for cocktail is much more
difficult so we can see that by by 30
days post infection even if we infect
the low-dose 100 bacteria per fly or
high dose you can see a marked increase
in replication from 6 to 30 days we can
also use a polyclonal antibody to
recognize coxiella antigens and infected
flies so you can see these cocktail
antigens are the same ones that are
recognized in just the infection
inoculum and then we can see that
there's an innate immune response in the
fruit flies as marked by the induction
of this antimicrobial peptide culture
Sosin so an infected flies at 12 days
post infection we get activation of this
antimicrobial peptide that's primarily
activated by an immune pathway in flies
that mediates gram-negative bacteria
infection so we look at a pathway that's
induced during a gram-positive bacterium
we don't see induction of this molecule
called defensin in these infected flies
so again only the the pathway that's
activated by a gram-negative bacteria
get activated and again coxiella is a
gram-negative bacteria so what cells
does coxiella in fact on the fly so
normally in mammalian systems coxiella
infects monocytes circulating in the
blood so we wanted to ask well the
equivalent to blood cells in the fly is
called a chemo site and we asked are the
chemo sites getting infected so we did
is we used Drosophila larvae and put
them on a plate of of coxiella let them
then we would poke prick the flies so
that the bacteria can invade and in fact
the the larvae then we would dissect out
these larvae to extract the hemo site
from these infected animals at 24 hours
after they were infected so then this is
just a picture from our technician
extracting the hemolymph and that the
hemolymph contains those hema sites then
we would image the chemo sites but I can
focal microscopy so a couple things is
we used we used a fly strain that has
GFP reporter in the chemo sites so all
he Messiah
have GFP mm and we also used a coxiella
strain that has that is tagged with M
cherry so we would do 3d reconstruction
and we could cross section on these Hema
sites again the Hema sites are GFP
coxiella has the hem cherry tag and then
we were also stained the nucleus with
Daffy so we can see coxa Fornetti
intracellular in the in these in these
Hema sites and we did a 3d
reconstruction model to show and we
would take cross sections to show the
bacterium inside the cells so here's a
video so that the Hema sites pinning
them we could take these cross sections
and we can see the coxiella enter
labeled coxiella inside of that cells in
here again so that's the whole 3d model
take the cross section we can see the
entry labeled coxiella so i mentioned
earlier that the toll and IMD pathways
respond to bacterial infections
so again if you remember coxiella
activates Josephson here and this is
mediated by the peptidoglycan receptor
protein which activates molecule
molecules called red fat and I MD or I
am immune deficient and will activate in
an F Kappa B molecule called relish that
causes the induction of these
antimicrobial peptides on the other hand
the toll pathway on responds to fungal
infections or gram positive bacteria
infections has a number of adapter
molecules that will then cause the
activation of transcription factors
mostly dorsal and dorsal immunity factor
and this causes the induction of defense
and so if you remember back to a couple
slides the toll defensin was not induced
during coxiella infection but person was
induced so we found in our coxiella
model that the loss of relish but not
PGR plc would result in increased
bacterial implication and reduced a MP
induction again just to go back to the
pathway so we're now knocking out either
IMD RP
ERP or sorry PG RP or relish in the
fruit flies and then looking at how
coxiella replicates so here looking at
so both PG RP and relish mutant flies
succumb faster to bacterial to coxiella
infection but only the relish mutant
flies show increased levels of bacterial
replication as compared to wild-type W
11:18 flies then we looked at draw so
seen that antimicrobial peptide read out
and observe that the relishing flies
they don't induce Josephson at all but
even these PG RP even if I still show
levels of docent induction so then we we
hypothesize that once Cox eel is
replicating PG our plc signaling is
length is less was is less active and
the infection instead activates relish
for subsequent a MP induction through an
alternative mechanism is this
alternative mechanism that we're
pursuing and we think that that it's
replicating coxiella generates an immune
response media by an intracellular
receptor and that's and we're
hypothesizing that intracellular
receptor is the sting molecule so just
to take us back to this pathway we think
that that molecule called sting is
activating somewhere in this pathway
that's further downstream of
peptidoglycan receptor signaling but
upstream of of relish signaling so we're
looking at you know how does it
activated immunity at this adapter level
so drosophila encodes a sting ortholog
so this is a plus ttle alignment of
sting from a number of diverse species
and we can see good alignment
here's drosophila second from bottom we
can see the wax sorry bollocks
here's mouse and human and i'm
highlighting here in red the cyclic die
nucleotide binding domains so these are
the domains that bind the molecule that
activates sting that's like um cyclic
g8g cyclic GMP cyclic die
and you can see in all of the alignments
you can see very high levels of
conservation at the cyclic die Geum
cyclic dinucleotide binding domains and
here I'm zooming in so here's a cyclic
die GMP and with human sting it's been
the the proteins been crystallized coker
size width cyclic dinucleotide and it's
been shown exactly which amino acids
bind to which molecules or interact with
which molecules of cyclic die GMP
if we look at those amino acid residues
in Drosophila sting you can see very
good conservation and identity in some
cases of these exact residues in
Drosophila sting as compared to human
sting so we believe that this this force
awful Houma is indeed the bonafide
homolog of the mammalian sting so again
these experiments are carried up on your
grad student lab marina in an undergrad
marina in the lab so we we found that
Drosophila sting can bind to cyclic die
GMP this is doing in vitro translation
assay where we in vitro translate human
or Drosophila sting or truncations so
this is just the end the end terminus of
Drosophila sting 1 to 133 or the C
terminal that contains those cyclic die
GMP binding domains you can see that we
can pull down cyclic GMP with human
sting for self listing not the end
terminal but the C terminal portion that
contains the binding domains we can see
interaction with cyclic die GMP if we do
so if we make some deletion meetings
where we delete I'm certain cyclic
dynamically type binding regions 1 2 or
3 when we delete one in 3 we get reduced
binding activity but if we delete 2 we
can still see decent binding with cyclic
die GMP and also these molecules are
able to activate NF Kappa B so the
Drosophila version of abstain can
activate human NF kappa-b
is the full-length protein so you can
see very high induction of NF kappa-b if
we delete cyclic dinucleotide domain 1
and 3 we get reduced enough Kappa B
activity if we delete 2 we get slightly
reduced activity but not as significant
as compared to the deletion of 1 and 3
so cyclic dying champion does indeed
induce a Drosophila sting mediated
immune response so what we did here is
we knocked out sting in Drosophila s 2
cells and then either mock treated them
or transfected them with cyclic die GMP
and you can see that when we knock out
sting we can see these genes are not as
highly induced as when we use a
scrambled double strand RNA so this is a
normal immune response so you can see
some of these antimicrobial peptides
that are being induced such as tasin and
and then if we categorize these these
genes into genome by gene ontology into
certain categories we can see that so
scrambled RNA and containing sting we
see induction of these gene pathways
defense response to bacterium into
bacterial human response defense
response but in cells that are knocked
out for sting you can see there aren't
any red bars here because none of the
none of these gene categories are
significantly up regulated Drosophila
sting again retains the ability to
activate NF kappa-b
so now we're looking at mouse hammering
fire blasts that have been transformed
with human sting or Drosophila sting and
treated with cyclic die GMP so we can
see and both that we can see
translocation of NF kappa-b there is
media by both human and Drosophila sting
but we don't see that Drosophila sting
can mediate an IRF 3 pathway so again
the point is that human sting can
activate both NF kappa-b and I are three
but the Drosophila honk only activates
NF kappa-b and has lost the ability to
activate ir 3 we verified this by
western blotting so again these same
cells
tree of a cyclic dinucleotide we can see
phosphorylation of I Kappa B the
inhibitor of NF kappa-b
so when this becomes phosphorylated I
Kappa B gets degraded and allows and if
Kappa B to translocate to the nucleus
but cyclic dinucleotide was only able to
activate the phosphorylation of higher 3
via human sting not via Drosophila sting
so in excess how is Drosophila sting
regulate relish
during infection so we relish is that
Drosophila homolog of NF Kappa B so how
based on the the results we have here
saying that sting can activate NF
kappa-b how does it activate relish
during infection so we can what we did
is we made a Drosophila overexpressing
fly that we infected with Listeria and
Listeria is a pathogen that's been well
known and well characterized to secrete
cyclic die GMP so in our Drosophila
sting overexpressing flies we see
increased activation of relish and
that's characterized by increased levels
of this 50 kill at all in 49 Killa
Delton processed piece of relish so the
c-terminal gets it gets cleaved and is
retained in the nucleus while the other
portion can translocate but by western
blotting you can see increased levels of
relish activity which then activates
these antimicrobial peptides sucker pin
a2 so again in our sting overexpressing
fly we get increased levels of Secor pin
i'm and again that's mediated by relish
but Jerusalem Ison which is mania by the
toll pathway we do see some increased
induction and there's just half listing
over Express and fly but it's not as
significant as the as secretin so next
question is where in the IMD pathway the
sting signaling occurred so what we did
here is we may use our Drosophila sting
overexpressing fly and we we put that
gene onto other flies that were able to
contain RNA I for parts of this pathway
so we we made at the we made in the same
fly the ability of sting
overexpression at the same time that
there could be RNA I knock out of these
genes so again the part of the toll
pathway and part of the IND pathway so
we did it so we have all of our so you a
SDM sting means we're driving Drosophila
sting over over expression and at the
same time we're knocking out parts of
this pathway
um luciferase RNA so that's just
nonspecific RNA I and then we infected
those flies with Listeria and we can see
that Secor pin that IMD me here so when
we knock out when we overexpress
sting and knock out either relish or IMD
we get the loss of sacrifi induction but
overall the the over expression of sting
we can see that there's an increase in
antimicrobial peptide induction during
Listeria infection ask as compared to
when the the lack of the lack of
Drosophila sting over expression and
then looking at droves of Meissen that I
am that toll pathway reporter we can see
that there's really no loss in interest
of Ison induction during the over
expression of staying and knockdown of
these pathways we do see some sun loss
when relishes knocked out but there's a
lot of crosstalk between these two
pathways and again relish some major
mediator of the innate immune response
we expected that the loss of relish
could impact Oh some ice and induction
of it some the the final steps that were
taking for is to exploit the sting
pathway to potentially inhibit coxiella
infection so going back to Congress no
there's really no good therapy for for
infection people who are infected with
cocktail it's a chronic infection within
the only way to treat infection is by is
by years of antibiotic treatment and in
animals there's no vaccine there's no
good therapeutic treatment and the only
way really to deal with a cocktail
infected animal herd is to is to kill
the animals so we want to think about
other ways
impact or health treat toxiel infections
again by exploiting the steam pathway so
first we looked at levels of cocktail
replication and we found that in Mouse
I'm reading fiberglass lacking sting we
saw increased levels of coxiella
infection as compared to wild-type
fiberglass and then looking at so this
is GFP labeled coxiella we can see
increased amount of GFP signal and
enlarger cocktail containing vacuoles in
the sting knockout fart glasses compared
to wild-type and then what we did is we
try to prime we tried to activate sting
before infection using cyclic
dinucleotides so if we primed or in if
we treated cells with cyclic
dinucleotide and then infected them with
coxiella we saw that there was decreased
levels of cocktail replication in primed
cells as compared to wild-type cells
ultimately we want to you know so this
is looking at the mouse system with of
coxiella in sting but we wanna use
Drosophila as a model for other insect
vectors of cocktail infection so in
addition to ruminant animals as being a
major source of coxiella cocktail is
found in tick populations and here were
lining the sting molecule in humans
Drosophila and the tick genome looking
at these cyclic die nucleotide binding
domains again we can see pretty good
similarity and these binding domains
especially 2 & 3 between human and and
tick sting now of course the tick is not
a good animal model to study infection
but if we can use Drosophila as another
insect that that's a way to you know
take a look into how potentially insects
largely coxiella infection so again
looking overall we want to look at you
know cocktail infection which produces
these bacterial cyclic nucleotides to
activate sting we want to see how this
pathway becomes activated and then can
we use exhaustion as cyclic
dinucleotides to activate sting and
ultimately potentially decrease cocktail
infection so again delineate the role of
stinger
infection dissect this pathway and then
prying the hosts immune response and
cyclic dangly tights before infection
then coming back to the overall goal of
the lab is to use multiple diverse
species to uncover evolutionarily
conserved host factors that are critical
to the host response to infection
and with that this is my mellotron
slideshow not everyone in the lab had a
recent outing at a Japanese restaurant
I'll think I'll thank Begum there's time
I can take questions from the audience
thank you yes okay you talked about in
human cells sorry there's a lot of I
couldn't really hear the question New
York the activation of staying in human
cells versus so you talk about being a
daddy practically to be does it activate
made in drop or in humans influenza
yeah so um so the mall at the NF kappa-b
homolog in Drosophila is called relish
and sting the southla version of sting
activates relish and the human version
of sting activates NF kappa-b what
they're that they're the same they're
again almost identical molecules they
both translocate to the nucleus and then
then activate the induction of innate
immune genes okay okay next question is
is pathogenic reject carry a hairy eye
disease disease
oh okay so what makes it so pathogenic
is that the fact that it can when it
infects a cell it infects the cell in
this slow metabolic form so the small
cell variant that that infection then
goes in into a vacuole and then the
bacteria actually replicates and becomes
metabolically active in a protected
vacuole within the cell and inside that
protected vacuole the bacteria is
actually in a different compartment from
the innate immune response so in that in
that vacuole it can replicate and that's
actually a very acidic vacuole and it
can replicate and it actually steals the
metabolic energy of the cell so people
who animals and humans who are
chronically infected with coxiella one
of the major symptoms is fatigue because
the bacteria is essentially taking all
that metabolic energy replicating in
this protective niche in the cell that
doesn't see some of these innate immune
mediators and we think that the cyclic
dinucleotides could be escaping from
that vacuole and activating sting but
then again sting can't the results of
sting activation are aren't able to
reduce an infectious load inside that
inside that vacuole but it's as little
as one bacteria can get in and start
replicating in the vacuole and can cause
a chronic infection Wow so just like
just like yeah so how do exactly I think
the delivery so the idea of using you're
referring to the idea of using cyclic
dinucleotides as a therapeutic yes
Zachery yes yeah so I think the the
biggest challenge would be delivery of
the molecule and then delivery of the
molecule in a form that wouldn't cause
hyper activation so again you know going
back to the very beginning of my
presentation talking about the ability
of
if there's hyperactivation of an immune
response an absence of infection you can
get sort of this autoimmune disease so
we wouldn't want to deliver the
therapeutic to cause you know some sort
of adverse hyper activation of an eighth
immunity but we need to deliver it in a
way that it would be less potent until
an infection occurs okay and so you
talked about it's a good question so
West Nile infects dogs cats and horses
you know some of the larger in mammalian
models I guess we just talked to the
reason I brought up horses is because
our our vet school is actually one of
the diagnostic labs for West Nile
infection and in horses in this industry
this essentially all of the Pacific
Northwest including Washington Idaho
Montana so it is a diagnostic lab where
a lot of infected horses are seen so
there was a I think last August two
horses came to our came to our unit so
we were able to you know the vets were
able to deal with them I guess
infected cats and dogs are brought here
so often right how are they yeah I think
you know moving that you know some of
those studies to any kind of clinical
application would be more difficult that
was actually one of the you know one of
the discussion points is you know we
wouldn't I guess it would be difficult
to say oh let's just put a bunch of IV
six in these mammalian models especially
if they come in after they're infected
yeah I don't think that would probably
work very well but again you know coming
back to one of our ideas of like priming
the immune system is that a way to to
reduce the load but again if there's an
if there's if we know where those horses
were infected or any of those animals
were infected so where those mosquitoes
are circulating and potentially we could
treat the on an you know the yet to be
infected horses as part of a herd on the
farm as an example great thank you
thank you